>> President Trump: PRISON
REFORM IS AN ISSUE THAT UNITES
PEOPLE FROM ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
AN AMAZING THING.
OUR WHOLE NATION BENEFITS.
IF FORMER INMATES ARE ABLE TO
RE-ENTER SOCIETY AS PRODUCTIVE
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
SEEKING COMMON GROUND ON AN
ISSUE LONG CHAMPIONED BY THE
LEFT BUT MANY DEMOCRATS
OBJECTED TO A PRISON REFORM
BILL THE HOUSE JUST PASSED.
HERE TO TELL US WHY IS
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLINS FROM
GEORGIA WHO CON SPONSORED THE
FIRST STEP -- CO-SPONSORED THE
FIRST STEP ACT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE LATE.
YOU DO SOMETHING WITH HAKEEM
JEFFRIES, ISN'T HE PUSHING
IMPEACHMENT OF TRUMP?
I CAN'T REMEMBER.
IT ALL CONFUSES ME.
THAT IS SOMETHING PEOPLE WANT
MORE OF, BIPARTISAN WORK.
AND YET THE DEMOCRATS ARE KIND
OF ALL TORN UP ABOUT THIS.
EXCEPT HAKEEM AND OTHERS.
>> I THINK WHAT YOU FIND HERE
WHEN YOU GET A PRESIDENT WHO
IS WILLING TO WORK ON ISSUES
AND WHO IS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WORKING CLASS AND CONCERNED
ABOUT EVERYBODY IN AMERICA,
PUTTING US FIRST.
YOU REACH OUT AND MY PARTNER
ON THIS, WE UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU CAN ACTUALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES.
ISN'T THAT WHAT WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT?
MAKING DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND GIVING HOPE TO THOSE
IN CELLS NOW.
THESE THINGS.
WHEN YOU VOTE AGAINST THE
BILL, IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT AND
YOU VOTED AGAINST THE BILL YOU
VOTED TO KEEP THE LADIES
SHACKLED GIVING BIRTH IN
PRISON.
YOU VOTED TO NOT LET, OR THOSE
WHO NEED HELP WHEN THEY COME
BACK OUT, OVER 90% OF THE
FOLKS COME BACK OUT OF PRISON,
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
DOING A GOOD JOB SPENDING
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO MAKE SURE
WE PUT THOSE AWAY THAT NEED TO
BE LOCKED AWAY LIKE MS-13.
THEY NEED TO BE LOCKED AWAY
FOREVER OR PUT AWAY.
WE NEED TO TAKE THOSE COMING
BACK OUT TO SOCIETY TO GIVE
THEM TOOLS LIKE THE PRESIDENT
SAID TO BE PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS
WHEN THEY COME BACK OUT.
>> Laura: SECOND CHANCE AT
REDEMPTION IS A POWERFUL
NARRATIVE IN THE LITERATURE
AND THE COUNTRY'S HISTORY.
GIVE MONEY TO NEW FUNDING FOR
PRISON REENTRY PROGRAMS AND WE
SPEND MONEY ON RECIDIVISM SO
YOU SAVE MONEY IF IT WORKS BUT
IT IS DIVIDING THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
KAMALA HARRIS AGAINST IT, CORY
BOOKER AGAINST IT.
THEY ARE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
AND THEY WANT TO SHORE UP THE
LEFT WING EVEN THOUGH THE LEFT
WAS FOR THIS.
VAN JONES SAID THIS ON CNN
TODAY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IF YOU HOLD OUT FOR
EVERYTHING, SOMETIMES YOU GET
NOTHING.
NOW THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
WE HELD OUT FOR EVERYTHING AND
WE WOUND UP WITH NOTHING.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO LEARN
ABOUT THIS COUNTRY IS THAT
WHERE WE DISAGREE, WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO FIGHT AND FIGHT
HARD.
BUT DON'T FORGET WHERE WE
AGREE WE ARE SUPPOSED TO WORK
TOGETHER AND WORK TOGETHER
HARD, ESPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE A VOICE.
>> Laura: WELL, HE WAS
SUPPORTING, AT THE EVENT,
SUPPORTING THE PRISON REFORM
BILL.
HE IS BEING TRASHED.
A TWEET TODAY, OLIVER WILLIS
ON VAN JONES.
VAN PROVIDES WINDOW DRESSING
SO RACIST ADMINISTRATION CAN
POINT TO THEIR BLACK FRIEND
WITHOUT REALLY DOING ANYTHING.
>> IT'S AMAZING.
WHAT HAS BECOME OF MANY OF
THESE ATTACKS ON THIS AND
ATTACKS ON VAN LIKE THAT,
TALLRANCE IS AGREE WITH ME.
WHAT WE HAVE BECOME IS WHEN WE
ACTUALLY EXPRESS VIEWS LIKE
YOU SAID, YOU FIGHT FOR THINGS
YOU BELIEVE IN.
YOU FIND AREAS OF AGREEMENT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A GROUP RIGHT
NOW THE LEFT SAYING WE WANT
MORE AND WE WANT MORE, THEY
HAVE SAYING WE DON'T WANT TO
WE LIKE THE ISSUE.
WE LIKE THE FACT WE'LL BE ON
THIS ISSUE AND NOT HELP
ANYBODY.
>> Laura: THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THE BLACK VOTE TURNING
EVEN 5% MORE FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
GIVING THEM A CHANCE.
MAYBE LISTENING TO THEM.
THEY DON'T WANT THAT.
CONGRESSMAN, I'M GLAD YOU ARE
DOING WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
KEEP DOING MORE OF IT.
THIS IS YOUR THIRD TERM IN
CONGRESS.
YOU WANT TO BE HERE MUCH